[R&B music playing]
♪ ♪
- You look beautiful
tonight.
both: Thank you.
- Who are you talking to?
- My beautiful wife,
of course.
Not my beautiful best friend.
♪ ♪
- David, Joy.
- [laughing] Hey.
- Hey.
- Can you believe
your dad is turning 60?
So old!
You know what
he needs to do?
Start eating soft foods
so he won't
have to get dentures
in a minute.
- That's not how teeth work,
David.
- Huh?
- Okay.
We better go work
on our speeches for your father.
- Y'all better bring
your A-game.
I've got a little something
special planned for tonight.
- You don't have to say that
to Sam.
He kills it every year.
- Ah, I guess I do, don't I?
[both laughing]
- All right, see you guys.
- Later.
- [sighs] These speeches
make me so nervous
'cause you know Dad's
just gonna pick it apart.
- [chuckles]
Ums and ahs
let the audience know
you're not prepared.
- You know what
you're gonna say?
- Please. I spent
the last year crafting
two pages of hilarious jokes
about Dad's mustache.
- Damn.
That is good.
- Hey, happy birthday,
Lawrence!
- Oh, hey, Mom.
Hi, Daddy.
- My darling.
[chuckles]
[classy music playing]
Son.
♪ ♪
[dramatic music]
[page crashes to the floor]
- [in slow motion]
Dad, you...
you shaved your mustache.
- Yes, son.
One should never stop evolving.
Now, if you'll excuse me,
I have to welcome my guests.
[laughs]
- Look at you two
all dressed up. [laughs]
- Mommy.
- Come here, sweetie.
- Hey, Mommy.
- And Tim, look at you.
Give me a twirl.
[funk music playing]
Come on!
I love it!
[laughter]
- Greetings.
Greetings, all of you.